creates good paying middle middle-class
jobs
strengthens our infrastructure and
confronts climate change
secures public safety makes housing more
affordable
ensures that every new yorker has a roof
over their heads
and an yes bold reforms for our state
government
my fellow new yorkers this agenda is for
you
every single initiative is filtered
through the lens of how it'll help you
and your families
because i know you're exhausted i know
you want this pandemic to be over
i know you're worried about the economy
inflation your kids their education and
what the future holds
we have endured so much hardship over
these past two years
we've buried loved ones
experienced seismic shifts in our daily
lives
and missed out on so many of life's
precious milestones holidays weddings
granulations
even the birth of a grandchild
there's been so much loss too many lives
and too many of our hopes and dreams
and now just we thought we were turning
a corner there's a new variant another
surge in cases it feels like deja vu
i know you're all asking
will we ever get through this
yes
we will
we're new yorkers
we've been knocked down before we've
been counted out but in response we
never fail to defy the odds and rise to
new heights new york always rises from
the ashes
and that is what i believe
this is not a moment of despair
but a moment of great possibility
because while we're in the midst of an
all-consuming crisis we also remember
that if we make the right choices right
now
it will end
first we must weather the storm around
us and that means controlling this virus
but not letting it control us when i
took office we immediately enacted a
comprehensive pandemic plan
we continue to adapt as new variants
like omicron have emerged
we're doing everything we can to keep
new yorkers healthy
setting policies that have made our
vaccination rate one of the highest in
the country
activating a military-style operation
with vacs and test sites
deploying the national guard to our
hospitals and nursing homes and sending
out 37 million kids across the state
state
during this winter surge our laser focus
is on keeping kids in school
businesses open and new yorkers lives as
normal as possible
we're attacking this virus head-on
armed with a tactical science-based
approach
and we are ready for whatever comes next
but as we all know too well this is more
than a public health crisis
we now need to support the people the
places the industries that were hit the
hardest
starting with new yorkers have been on
the front line since day one
during those terrifying early months
while many hunkered down at home
our health care workers and first
responders showed up
day after day night after night double
shift after double shift putting their
lives on the line to save others
they're not only physically exhausted
they're emotionally exhausted too
i know i've seen it in their eyes in
hospitals from buffalo to potsdam just
this last week
that exhaustion combined with
pre-existing staffing shortages has
resulted in a crisis
we simply do not have enough health care
workers in our hospitals or in our
long-term care facilities
in our ambulances or in the homes of our
loved ones
the health of every new yorker depends
on strong stable and equal health care
system
and these workers are its very
foundation
bold action is required before any more
time passes
first we must stop the current
hemorrhaging of health care workers
and we're going to do it
not just by saying we owe them a debt of
gratitude but actually paying them the
debt we owe
starting with a retention bonus of up to
three thousand dollars for our health
and direct care workers that'll help
drive salaries throughout the healthcare
workforce
so those doing god's work here on oath
are no longer paid a minimum wage
beyond
salaries
will make it easier for doctors and
nurses from other states to practice
with their existing licenses here in new
york
we'll expand the capacity of our medical
institutions so more students can train
for high demand health care jobs
and will make it possible for them to
get that training with free tuition and
stipends if they remain here after they
graduate
a once-in-a-lifetime pandemic demands a
once-in-a-lifetime response
and that's why i'm setting an ambitious
goal to grow our health care workforce
by 20 percent over the next five years
and will make the largest investment in
health care in states history
10 billion dollars
you know as we bolster our bone tired
health care workforce we know they
aren't the only heroes of the pandemic
i am so grateful to the county leaders
school superintendents administrators
parents and teachers who work so closely
with us
to kids get kids back to school just
this week
the role of a teacher is irreplaceable
in a child's life
and as the last two years have tamered
home they're irreplaceable in a parent's
life too
as a mother i know this firsthand
this workforce is also stressed and
overworked
so we'll ramp up efforts to recruit and
retrain teachers with more effective
training and support
faster and earlier certification
and stronger career pipelines and
ladders
and
we will add more mental health
professionals in schools to help heal
the wounds inflicted during the
isolation of remote learning
others are hurting as well
families small business owners farmers
they all need our help
and they need it now
and they're going to get it we will
accelerate a 1.2 billion dollar tax cut
originally scheduled to take effect
between now and 2025 so that it occurs a
lot earlier that's means more than six
million middle-class taxpayers will get
more money in their pockets sooner
at a time when inflation is robbing them
of any gains in income
to help with property taxes we'll
provide a 1 billion middle-class
property tax rebate to more than two
million homeowners
and help get parents back to work
we're going to expand access to
affordable child care to 100 000 more
working families
and invest 75 million in child care
worker wages
and we will deliver 100 million dollars
in much needed relief to nearly 200 000
small businesses to keep their doors
open and weather with the next few
months spring
these businesses are the economic
engines of small towns and big cities
alike
they're what make our communities unique
and give them personality
i should know i've shopped and eaten
diners and most of them
also i helped my mother start a small
flower shop and my sister started a tech
company so i know firsthand how hard it
is i know the risk taken by owners and
entrepreneurs
and the barriers faced by women
so many small businesses are pushed to
the brink thousands of bars and
restaurants the soul of our
neighborhoods have had to close
for others hanging on by a thread
survival depends on whether they can
create more space outdoors
a tough test during our new york winters
to help offset these costs
we'll provide a tax credit for covet
related purchases like outdoor heating
and seating
we're also going to do something our
bars and restaurants have been asking
for to once again allow the sale of to
go drinks a critical revenue stream
during the lean times last year so
cheers new york
and the farmers who supply our
restaurant kitchens and not our own
they need a lifeline as well
i visited farms from genesee county to
the north fork of long island and life
is tough even in good years
so we're going to support them
through a tax credit for the overtime
hours they are paying an increase in the
infant investment tax credit
and an extension and doubling of the
farm workforce retention credit
this will also begin to address the
workforce shortage many farms struggle
with as well
so
this is how we'll begin to help health
care workers
educators small businesses farms and
families
deal with the devastating economic
impacts of coving
but beyond the pandemic
my agenda reflects my belief that we
cannot allow this virus to grip us so
tightly that it constrains us from
looking to the future
and longing for a simple return to our
pre-pandemic world and way of life would
only not only be timid and unimaginative
it would ignore our history and go
against everything that makes new york
new york
if we can't embrace the possibilities
that come out at times like these
then we failed to honor the legacy of
the daring visionary new yorkers who
came before us
the portrait of franklin roosevelt that
hangs above the mantle in the governor's
residence is my daily reminder of what
leadership during a crisis is all about
first as governor
and then as president
fdr literally rebuilt the economy from
the ground up after the crash of 29
but more than giving people jobs
he gave people hope
the policies of his new deal didn't just
help families who lost everything
they spurred decades of economic growth
and the birth of the middle class
again and again he focused on the storm
swirling around him but kept one eye on
the horizon
always planning for the day when the
clouds would part
that is exactly what we are doing now
this pandemic did not create all the
problems we're facing today
it simply forced us to hold up a mirror
and see the cracks in our society that
have been so easy to ignore before
this crisis has created an opportunity
to redefine ourselves and we must
embrace it
but as we embark on this new era for our
state we need to take a hard look in
that mirror and deal with harsh
realities
like the fact that 300 000 new yorkers
left our state last year alone
that's the steepest population drop of
any state in the nation an alarm bell
that cannot be ignored
to those who left temporarily because of
the pandemic
or trying to decide their next steps
during these uncertain times
i have one message
you do not want to miss what's going to
happen next
right now in real time we're building a
new new york worthy of your talents and
your ambitions
we're going to jump start our economic
recovery by being the most business
friendly and worker-friendly state in
the nation
to entice people and businesses we're
investing millions of dollars to
transform the downtowns of our cities
into magnets for new jobs and
opportunities
and position both legacy and emerging
industries for success
we all know new york is already home to
some of the most consequential
industries in the world
finance retail healthcare technology
fashion entertainment just to name a few
but there's plenty of room for growth
more shovel ready sites for new
manufacturers and warehouses
improvements in our freight
infrastructure
and investments in the technology
that'll power the jobs of the future
and we're going to make sure that we
have a workforce trained to step into
these jobs
that's why we'll invest smartly and
strategically in workforce development
programs
which simply means matching people to
training to jobs
i know the demand is strong
at every one of the thousands of
workplaces i've visited the universal
complaint is not having enough trained
workers
every single place it's the same
and that's why we'll reboot our
workforce development office
how is it an empire state development so
it can build stronger relationships with
employers
and move funding through our regional
economic development councils
so we can grow programs that train for
jobs are actually in demand in different
parts of the state
and the smart way to do this is to have
school districts community colleges suny
and cuny all focused on the same
objectives
we're going to incentivize success
by tying a portion of workforce funding
to high job placement rates
and we're going to make it easier to
qualify than mwbe so everyone has access
to opportunities
it's a common sense approach
unbacked by an uncommon level of funding
and it's going to help supercharge our
economy
our goal is for new york to be known as
nationally as the place that grows and
attacks attracts the talent and the
businesses will follow
and for businesses to succeed they need
a well-trained and educated workforce
and i believe to my very core that
there's nothing more valuable than
education and training when it comes to
unlocking opportunity and prosperity
it changes lives across generations
i know what education did in my own
family's circumstances
my grandparents fled ireland as
teenagers because they had nothing they
were poor with no hint of opportunity in
their home country
my grandfather first became a migrant
farm worker in the fields of south
dakota
then later he and grandma were domestic
workers that all changed when he heard
those great jobs in a place called
buffalo new york at the bethlehem steel
plant and grandma found a job at bell
aerospace making parts for our planes
during world war ii
that was their ticket to the life that
they came in search of
what really transformed my family
was the fact that my father was able to
get a college degree at night
while working by day at the same steel
plan as his father
if he hadn't taken that leap
and invest in his own education i would
be living a very different life today
my whole family would be
and that's why i'm so focused on
expanding educational opportunities
starting by making the state's tuition
assistance program available to
part-time students
i believe that suny and cuny are the
engines of social mobility
and have untapped potential that still
needs to be unharmed unleashed and
harnessed
so today
i'm outlining a vision to make suny
the best statewide public higher
education system in the nation
how
first recruiting world-class faculty
and creating a flagship institutions at
stony brook and the university at
buffalo
investing more in our premier research
facilities at binghamton and albany and
leaning into the strengths of our
four-year comprehensive colleges our
technology colleges and our community
colleges
but also providing child care on each
campus let's increase enrollment to 500
000 students by 2030
making suny a national leader on equity
and increasing the number of diversity
in every community
with degrees and credentials that have
lost middle-class careers
and ensuring that suny campuses spur
economic growth in their own surrounding
communities
as we upgrade our statewide higher
education institutions
we also have to acknowledge their
populations at risk of falling through
the cracks unless we target job training
and educational opportunities to them as
well
for example we know that incarcerated
people who participate in correctional
education programs are far less likely
to reoffend
and 13 times more likely to obtain
employment after returning home
that outcome benefits the formerly
incarcerated
employers in need of workers and the
taxpayers of new york and it's the right
thing to do
so today i'm announcing a new jails to
jobs initiative so incarcerated people
have the support they need to find
employment during reentry
we're also going to restore the tuition
assistance program for incarcerated
people again ending a 30-year ban
as we create economic opportunity in
every sector
there's one industry that'll be working
around the clock for years to come
my friends in the construction trades
building infrastructure the likes of
which we've never seen
you know infrastructure can mean
different things to different people
to me it's exciting because it's all
about creating connections connecting
neighborhoods connecting people to jobs
and connecting people to their families
substandard infrastructure can mean long
commutes
lost time from family
even missing a child's bedtime
time time an entire repair shop after
hitting a pothole adds more stress than
anyone needs
and that's why i view building and
improving our infrastructure as a
quality of life issue
in november i still with my former
colleagues in congress on the white
house lawn when president biden signed
the historic infrastructure bill
giving us a once in a century chance to
invest
we cannot let this moment slip by and we
won't
new yorkers demand the best and that's
exactly what they're going to get
just look what my administration has
already announced over the past four
months
we'll finally transform penn station
into a world-class facility worthy of
our city
ensure the gateway project finally moves
forward
we'll deliver long overdue upgrades at
both laguardia and jfk airports
and finish the second avenue subway to
connect east harlem to jobs
but we're just getting started
today i'm announcing a bold idea
take an old unused 14 mile long right
away and create what we're calling the
inter borough express a new rail service
that'll connect brooklyn and queens
i'm directing the mta to immediately
commence an environmental review so we
can get that project rolling down the
track
i'm also directing the port authority to
get moving on the cross tunnel across
harvard home
as i said
infrastructure is all about connections
and we need to reconnect neighborhoods
that were severed by asphalt highways
disproportionately impacting communities
of color
we're going to reverse the damage that
was done more than half a century ago
with projects like the kensington
expressway in buffalo i-81 in syracuse
the inner loop in rochester and the
cross bronx expressway
you know i've traveled to every one of
our 62 counties in each of the past
seven years so i know every single road
and highway and bridge
and i think i have a personal experience
with just about every pothole in new
york as well especially on the long
island expressway
i'm coming after them too
we're making the largest ever investment
new york's digital infrastructure
putting one billion dollars into
connecting more new yorkers with
high-speed internet
this investment will boost innovation
and economic growth especially in our
most remote communities
there's one more piece of critical
infrastructure in our plan to rebuild
making it our infrastructure more
resilient against climate change
i remember just days after being sworn
into office we were slammed with
hurricane ida i walked the streets of
east helmers queens and witnessed the
aftermath of an epic collision between
mother nature and our inferior
infrastructure with devastating
consequences
it was a cruel reminder that too much
time has already been lost in the fight
against climate change
and these events are no longer rare
the next one is coming
look no further than upstate counties
constantly battered by so-called
500-year flooding
or the tunnels in new york city
and communities on long island still
undergoing repairs more than a decade
after hurricane sandy hit
this is a threat to our way of life here
and now
and that's why we must and we will
implement a vicious agenda to meet this
moment
we've already started with increasing
the environmental bond act to four
billion dollars to go on the ballot this
fall so we have the resources we need
i'm now announcing a nation-leading 500
million dollar investment in offshore
wind energy that'll create thousands of
good paying green jobs
as we build out our wind energy capacity
and continue our transition to clean
energy our reliance on fossil fuels must
be phased out
in september i announced two clean
energy mega projects to put us on a path
to achieve the ambitious goal of cutting
eighty percent of new york city's power
plant emissions by 2030.
new construction in the state will be
zero mission by 2027
and will build climate-friendly electric
homes and promote electric cars trucks
and buses
you know protecting our environment is
personal to me
i was born at a time and in a place
where orange smoke billowed out of the
factory smokestacks literally blocking
the skies with a horrible stench i can
still recall to this day
all the while dumping toxic waste into
one of the world's largest freshwater
lakes
i live surrounded by the causes of
climate change
and now i'm living with the effects
so while we confront climate crisis we
will address one of those basic of human
needs and that is to also feel safe
on streets in schools and in homes
time and time again new yorkers tell me
that they don't feel safe they don't
like what they see on the streets
and things feel different now and not
always for the better and it's not just
new york city it's cities all across
america
and many factors contribute to our state
our streets feeling less safe
including a very real uptick in gun
violence nationwide since the start of
the pandemic
now
this is not a return the dark days of
the 70s and 80s and 90s but that's not
our metric for success we need to get
back on track
in october i signed a bill that closed
loopholes in gun possession and
registration
making it easier for law enforcement to
track down weapons used in crimes and
prevent gun trafficking
and we ban the sale of ghost guns
going forward we will double down on
practical proven law enforcement
strategies to combat gun violence
working with mayor adams in new york and
the lieutenant governor i've who i've
asked to take lead for our
administration will form a new
consortium unprecedented cooperation
between new york state police the nypd
and other law enforcement agencies
including our neighboring states and
we'll trace guns used in crimes and stop
the flow of guns into our state
meanwhile will triple the resources for
both our gun tracing efforts as well as
for successful community-based programs
fighting gun violence is critical
we must address other factors
contributing to the pervasive unease
that many are feeling in our streets
and that includes the humanitarian
crisis unfolding right before us
the rise in street homelessness
our fellow new yorkers who are in this
situation deserve our compassion and
they will receive it along with our
support
we will create teams of mental health
professionals and social workers who
partner with new york city
and will reach homeless individuals and
move them into shelters and
housing but at the same time we know
that street homelessness only accounts
for a small fraction of the homeless
population
beyond those sleeping on the streets
tens of thousands more people move in
and out of shelters as they try to
secure a place to call home
and tragically
many of them are children
we need to focus on addressing the root
cause of homelessness
unmet mental health needs poverty
addiction and housing and security
every new yorker deserves access to
affordable housing
whether they're at the risk of
homelessness
or simply struggle to pay the rent on
time each month
so many people not only face tremendous
economic hardship but here's the double
hit
housing prices have also contributed to
escalate that possibility out of the
reach of many forcing this situation
even more
and that's why i'm launching a new
five-year housing plan to create and
preserve 100 000 affordable homes
including 10 000 units with supportive
services for high risk populations like
runaway youth and formerly incarcerated
individuals
and we can no longer ignore the plight
of nycha residents living in sometimes
deplorable conditions
the lieutenant governor and i will work
with the city of new york and this
legislature on concrete action this
section next section
so we'll also fix outdated land use laws
that hold back our housing supply
we'll encourage transit oriented
development
and the conversion of hotels and offices
into housing
is part of our overall housing strategy
now accomplishing everything i propose
thus far hinges on one thing
a government people trust
across the country trust in government
is reaching all-time lows we know why
misinformation and lies on social media
a widening partisan divide gridlock in
washington even outright attacks on the
right to vote
it's getting harder and harder for
people to believe in their elected
leaders at all levels of government
here's the question
how do we restore their faith
here in new york
our answer is to demonstrate what good
and honest governance looks like
we've already announced our first step
we are submitting a proposal to the
legislature to enact two term limits for
statewide officials
for government to work
those of us in power cannot continue to
cling to it
we need to continually pass the baton to
new leaders with different perspectives
and fresh ideas
our reforms include a ban on outside
income for statewide officials because
our only job should be to serve the
people of new york
but that's not the only part of the
system that's not working it's no secret
that recent events have called into
question the effectiveness of the joint
commission on public ethics j cope
i will introduce legislation to replace
that commission with a new ethics
enforcement watchdog one with real teeth
one that answers to new yorkers and not
politicians
none of these changes will fix our
government overnight but having these
safeguards in place
won't mean most of us in elective office
still won't stumble and make amount of
mistakes once in a while
by putting in much-needed reforms we can
at least begin to restore public trust
by focusing on what really matters to
our constituents
now what you've just heard is a mere
sampling
of more than 220 proposals that fill a
book that we're releasing today
quite an extraordinary accomplishment
given our 134 days in office
and i commend the hard-working staff who
help me shape this agenda
and i'm proud to have the most diverse
talented team new york state has ever
had
before we leave
and get to work
i want to pause a moment to reflect on
our state's unique history and the
destiny that lies before us
since its beginning our country has
attracted people from all around the
world in search of an ideal that made
leaving their homeland worth the risk
two simple words the american dream
and in pursuit of this millions found
their way here to us
new york has always meant the promise of
a better life
for those immigrating through ellis
island
fleeing slavery in the south
resettling here as refugees from
afghanistan
and our natives our state is nationally
recognized
as the birthplace of movements for
equality and progress the labor movement
the women's rights movement
the lgbtq plus movement
the environmental movement the racial
justice movement they're all started
right here by enlightened new yorkers
we attract the best the brightest the
boldest
we embrace and celebrate racial ethnic
and gender diversity culture and
entertainment where a single word like
broadway says it all
where the unsurpassed beauty of niagara
falls the adirondacks jones beach the
finger lakes erie canal and the hudson
river valley
as well as the grandeur of the new york
city skyline at glo at night it's
breathtaking
this is who we are
and we are proud of it
the keepers of the flames of the
movement's past
stewards of the national treasures
entrusted to us
and the visionaries who will lead our
state into the future
with courage and with confidence
while we may be imperfect
new york has always been the risk takers
the entrepreneurs the innovators the
builders the new immigrants the students
the true believers and the dreamers
who know that there truly is only one
new york
my fellow new yorkers
members of the legislature the time has
come for a new american dream
a better fair more inclusive version
that i call the new york dream
for new york is not just a place like
other states
it's also an ideal
one that embodies excitement energy and
endless possibilities
just as we are inspired by the history
bequeathed to us by the great new
yorkers who led our nation's social
justice movements
and leaders like i said like fdr who
navigate us through a crisis with a calm
steady hand
so too will history look back on our
time
how we are judged to be determined by
what we do right here
right now
let us seize this moment with great
confidence and optimism and create a
legacy of accomplishment that will
endure through the ages a new era for
new york
it might may god bless the people the
great state of new york and our nation
thank you
[Applause]
this joint session is adjourned
[Music]